no però senza vedere ma farò io
guardava 49 soggiorna zona perché quando
ha notato arrivo pero difficile da sole
cazzo ti piace tirarmi punita solo ma
eletto anche a letto prima di meritare
ben altri ragazzi veramente che sono io
sono parigi oggi sono qua con giampiero
cialente in un video e sono il capitano
non sbaglia
lui è già vi presento giampiero che
questo ragazzo che alla barba che io non
ho la barba
comunque siamo in questa stanza che
dall'ordine si intuisce che la stanza di
marco info ti amo il computer un'altra
volta
oggi giochiamo a geox non so se vi
ricordate quel sito che ti catapulta in
una parte del mondo completamente random
e tu devi capire dove sei
devi insegnarlo consuma ma potrebbero
anche in antartide di euro m che io sono
di 0 in geografia franchi 00 di oggi per
trovare il sito è stato un casino
chissà come finisce adesso non voglio
sapere ma lo vedremo start e new game
questa minore sarà il giardino di casa
mia
per questo sono io quando dio c'è ancora
questa dice ci stanno a papozze invece
sì magari attenzione io sono skillato
perché ho già fatto degli episodi so che
dei guardalinee è in corsa ctam i suns
agiati bestia svezia pro svezia norvegia
questo è per prendere il sole immagino
secondo me siamo in svezia
ok le case allora perché lista di snack
se ne va gestito con cotanta soltanto
per questo la ci sono tra poi per i
trattori
ci sono dei trattori questi conti sono
visti tedesi si guarda che raccolgono le
rocce sia sai che mi stai con wind in
the forest sono questi sono dei
maledetti perché tipico fu scanu i
cartelli
questi però vedi allora la conformazione
della casa messa veramente dico di
polonia primo tentativo quindi la cosa
vuoi fare polonia svezia mette un po in
mezzo certo per l'isola è questo mica ci
pensi dai ros e questa ne vado lo giuro
aism e chrome rifarti non devi
indovinare solo il posto proprio a
dominare che era quindi va bene è single
e possibilità è tanto sento veniamo
grazie ma non era magrissimo ben extra
questo non è milano sicuramente nome non
è mio india india questa meta di
gigliata assolutamente isola che l'india
è veramente grossa gli animaletti questo
consente questo è questa è una mini
torino un cane cane e le gare si sono
dei pesci kong e india si sia dobbiamo
andare di panino a spaccare proprio
cellule cui un sinistro destra per me
mumbai periferia di mumbai sparo da
allora era dalla parte 90 normale dai
ora i due stati struttura abbiamo
azzeccato pensa sera in fiches a cut up
atam pronto mamma non interferiscono in
più a milano visitata da katanga quando
capisci il posto viene approvato beh
questo è chiarissimo
ovviamente
attendiamo o targhe già all in one
l'italia non serve lenti colorate
secondo me sei la prima che dici tu sono
sbagliato si in colorado dove colorado
non ora comincia a pensare all'india e
tutte ste cose colorato e qua da noi
veniamo australian draw austra era il
bravo galles del sud ma comunque una
strada è bestia fossero solo lontana
13.000 chilometri dalla c'e niente di
particolare insomma questa mi sa un po
di italia aspetta set con konstantin non
è italia e piazza del duomo qualsiasi se
questo caso è uguale spirit è vero dove
dormire la macchina un passo c'è una
tipa in rosso noi è un tipo dov'è finito
mi fa marco lonzi vengono dal
supermercato ma mi becco non c'è niente
aspetta una bella protezione
e magari e romania romania polonia punto
però in romania bat o bellissima matrice
la mappa presissimo dimostrando accusa
moda amici di dove siete
ma si sa di roma rio cioè bella
stamattina vi è nessuna discriminazione
ma sa proprio di romania rap neumair
dalla di somma ai 312 km siamo a 4 e no
se mattino sul fatto davvero l c'è un
cartello nico indietro norvegia norvegia
appunto no mettiamo norvegia random o
una volta random azzeccheremo 50 270 che
ci stanno sempre centri di sommario
piacere lorenzo insomma mario dice
lorenzo è una sorellina barzelletta è
una barzelletta ridotti però va beh
bisogna dire di fareitalia generale che
di dargli delle generale dai vediamo
allora questo è chiaramente il nono isa
di isola e anche verso capri capri capri
e capri perché ne ventotenne non esiste
secondo me rtv capri ma non pensi a
capri però va bene qua immagini vediamo
noi cioè prevalga
non garanti guarda che race dies non
posso crederci marina piccola
no no sempre male no non è così alcun
incredibile tra tutte ma ponza o dannosi
che culo va bene la sapeva questa io lo
so io devo tirare un po il fantastico
duomo di duomo di spingere al duomo di
soprendere quindi succede stato ma
allora in nord e al nord italia si è il
vostro blè ma torino è la mia vera
torino si noi lo stiamo zitti malaka
gara da il testo posto che bella il
centro centro basso peso
la mia storia territorio vittoria che
vicino a un torinese che la mostra dove
il centro che cosa vuoi equa guarda poi
qui e qui credo sia qui ne aspetta da
146 metri dall altra ma d'altra parte è
certo la cella strada è sono scemo
israele dettagli
milano milano è single ed uomo e uomo di
milano venezia
che bella venezia è bello adesso l'ho
vista una volta io
ceniamo insieme facciamo sulle vongole
che facciamo io e te ok niente
quindi se la si vede la famosissima la
chiesa le leggi e lamezia
la nuova moschea ma che è in basilica
santa maria della salsa l'avrà mai vuol
dire che noi se da qui noi siamo quasi
ma cosa succede se non vedere se il
tetto ristorante diciamo un po di
ristoranti bar metti lo mettono solo
ascolti aspetto a mio parere che sono
nate aspetta un'altra chiesa
ok lecce della terra e si vedano è
giusto l'aquila 19 19 era quasi sul
punto ragazzi aveva sbarrati l'edificio
metriche porca vacca l'edificio dopo ma
puoi prendere il 100 per cento cioè
aveva azzeccato più pochi a torino ma
sta andando male no vabbè ovviamente
bologna roma se avrei messo si ok
vediamo un attimo allora penso sempre
bene no le ha messe dire chiude labria
reggio calabria contro le reti rai carlo
ci danno no non è vero che a venezia c'è
un po di pesce vela di venezia c'è un
ponte gigante mi sta facendo in
un'accogliente da venezia su una risorsa
incredibile è un ponte enorme a venezia
è vero per entrare così si è spesso r11
si è quello è quello mormon punto random
si è perfetto da mare si chiami caso in
due facili ma che bravi a parte lo sa ma
l'unico che non sembri dedizione non
siano stati spettacolari bronchi
precedenti si sono giocate perfetto ma
vera che abbiamo fatto il possibile
direi che non male soprattutto capre
capre incredibile si sistema meta sicuro
andiamo a nuoto anzi al noto ci facciamo
conterà la distanza del brutto che abbia
mancato che è un chilometro ciao ciao
panone verne
formigoni ragazzo quali spero che vi sia
piaciuto ringrazio gian piero per aver
partecipato e ringrazio lorenzo per
fatto partecipare quindi servite le
precisazioni 102mila ci si schieri e non
ci vediamo in un prossimo video non c'è
il telecomando non so come ciao
[Musica]